die stählernen überbleibsel einer der
größten schiffskatastrophe liegen in 35
meter tief
vor 100 jahren versanken hier 52
deutsche kriegsschiffe innerhalb weniger
stunden
der schauplatz des maritimen drama
stepper flow eine 15 kilometer breite
bucht in der mitte der orkney inseln im
nordosten schottlands bild-reporter
claudio fahrgasse begibt sich auf
spurensuche zu diesem untergegangenen
stück deutscher geschichte
er will aktuelle unterwasseraufnahmen
machen abtauchen in die vergangenheit
riesig
doch bei aller faszination für die
gesunkenen schiffe bleiben bei dem bild
reporter einige fragen offen was geschah
wirklich ins gab hoffnung wie konnten 52
kriegsschiffe gleichzeitig versenkt
werden ohne dass es die engländer
bemerkten und warum wurden am 21 juni 9
unbewaffnete deutsche soldaten ein
halbes jahr nach kriegsende erschossen